[Music]
hello all this mediation is here to help
facilitate your divorce you will all be
civilized and you will please address
all speech to me to you so even if we
want to talk to you alone uh that we can
I mean if I wanted to say Dina I am
going to have a beautiful life with your
husband Dean I can't believe he brought
her I can't believe you brought
Christine I can't believe you shacked up
with a [ __ ] I just say for the record I
just needed an upgrade in my life Deana
please I'm sorry you son of a [ __ ]
you're the son of a [ __ ] you're a son
of a [ __ ] yes 23 years of fairness just
down the shoes what am I gonna do
[Applause]
40-something pure woman that doesn't
even have her to create it hmm I know
what I'm gonna do let me see you don't
regret staying at home and being your
mom but I regret not getting my degree
that's why somebody's mom just enrolled
in college beep beep beep it's me
experience oh hell no I don't know
what's better it's the mom perm or the
mom's boobs these allowed this one to
suckle at these teeth for 28 months I
wear them around my office proudly isn't
the time get ready for the world
oh I cannot stay out of this
unbelievable chocolate it is we barked
so maybe I would probably hold off from
having any more just cuz I what is it
[Music]
for 40 years I've worried about what I
wasn't doing right what I could have
been doing better you have a moment here
if you take it mom don't jump to
conclusions you don't know what's
happening here
looks like my mother is doing the walk
of shame out of a frat house look it's
technically that's what's happening
watch though you know what I'm older I'm
wiser this essentially a Google ask me
anything
turn off your of a Google it can't be
turn I don't like it I did not know they
were gonna be here what is on your low
Dan it's an earring what works for
Harrison Ford
Harrison Ford blew up the Death Star and
free to galaxy what have you done damn
[Music]
you